>>Ready to hold your invention?
Yep.
>>Narrator: You see it everywhere,
on the walls in the hallway,
in classrooms, and on the lab
coats teachers wear every day:
the distinctive branding
of the National Aeronautics
and Space Administration.
>>Good Morning, Forest Lake.
Good morning.
>>Forrest Lake Elementary was one
of 150 schools across the country
to be selected for the NASA
Explorer Schools Program.
Designed to spark interest and
achievement in math, science,
and technology, the program
provided grants for technology tools,
summer teacher workshops,
curriculum materials,
and ongoing professional development.
>>Our focus is on twenty-first
century learners.
We know that for our
students to be prepared,
they need all that we can provide
in science, technology, engineering,
mathematics and NASA
seemed like a perfect fit.
>>We thank you.
>>It's no accident that the
school's TV studio looks a little
like Cape Canaveral.
And this morning's broadcast featured
a first grade team of inventors
who came up with a new twist
on the old drinking fountain
just in time for flu season.
>>Well the Sani-Sipper, there's a
tube that hooks up to this nozzle
and it has a detector causing the
sanitizer to clean it at every use.
>>Narrator: Beyond the curriculum
materials and grant money,
the association with NASA helps the
school build a sense of purpose.
>>We are very proud to be a NASA
Explorer School and so a lot
of things that a lot of teachers
use as really good practices
in their classroom to create a
classroom community I've just tried
to give a NASA spin.
So the copilot's responsibilities
are to assist me.
Anything that I need done, they do.
I've got a communications officer
and she's responsible for passing
out papers and taking
papers back in again.
An environmental officer maintains
the cleanliness of the classroom
so it creates a bond
in the community.
>>We are using videoconference
equipment to connect to NASA Langley.
>>Narrator: Students
in an after-school program have
direct access to NASA personnel
in Langley, Virginia
via a videoconference.
>>Our mission is the
superabsorbent polymers.
>>Today they are sharing
findings of their experiments
with a polymer used
to keep diapers dry.
>>The first step was I put
them in different cups.
One was polymer, one what
they did with the Dr. Pepper,
one they did with the
cranberry juice,
and the other they did
with the low-fat milk.
>>I wanted to think of something
that they could maybe have
in their everyday life but
had never thought too much
about the science behind it.
>>What attracted you to do
this type of experiment?
>>Tammy: It just sort of happened
that all girls came together.
I know that there's been
some research and some talk
about how girls and science,
they kind of fall behind
and let the boys sort of take over.
And with it being an all-girls
group some of them have stepped
up a little more than they would have
if we were mixed in
here with the boys.
>>Like when you think of a girl
you think oh yeah, oh nails.
But like in this we can be ourselves
and like we can get
down and get messy.
>>It's really cool to me to be
able to work with real people
that are actually experienced and I
kind of want to be an engineer there
because my grandfather
was an engineer with NASA.
>>It's really exciting working with
NASA and all my friends working
with NASA, it's really fun.
>>Narrator: Like many institutions,
NASA has been forced to make cuts
in its Explorer Schools
Program, but it continues
to offer free curriculum
materials on its website helping
to fuel a passion for
science and service.
>>I always wanted to help people
and be a surgeon or a doctor,
and so I'm like I really like NASA
and so I'm thinking about being,
I want to be a doctor there.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org